for anybody and not i feel like this is
how you
probably develop your own voice a lot of
times i don't really
go for the joke i'm not thinking of a
joke in my head i think what is best to
go on
is like go off of a feeling and you're
like why is this bothering me why do i
find this strange
what is about this thing that is so
weird or like
um like annoying you because you're like
it's so small or stupid
and then from there like sometimes just
the obsessiveness of thinking about
something you're like obviously
this is something very passionate to me
right now and i should probably
um think about why it's in my mind and
then i think that's
where i get the joke i like i the reason
why i record a set is because sometimes
you'll have this happen you'll have a
joke that's working really really well
on a consistent basis for a while and
then all of a sudden
out of the blue it stopped working
so then i have to go back and listen to
when it was working
and figure out what i was doing
differently
to what i'm doing now
every now and then it's because you
dropped a phrase you just i naturally
drop stuff
and it's not because i do it on purpose
it just
happens it feels like a lot more work
but you can really create your own
avenue
and that you know if you don't really
get seen by industry you could probably
have a really great fan base and still
make a really great living doing this
and honestly if industry sees that
you're pulling in money
somebody's going to want to take
advantage of that so i just always say
keep creating for yourself and doing
that
you know doing stuff that you enjoy and
i think people will
like it's kind of like the law of
attraction that
people will come to you you know to get
your voice seen
really you really should just be like
creating stuff and putting it online
because
we're online like 24 7. it's like a
cocktail party it's a great way for a
lot of people that wouldn't get to see
you see you and it's a
a good community i know a lot of people
hate twitter but i
if you learn to mute it and just treat
it as a joke machine
engage off of doing stuff like that or
writing sketches and putting videos up
like
that's such a great way for people to
see you
rather than like it's harder to go do
live stuff like
and get a huge audience base but you can
like
really find a community by like putting
your ideas up on online i think
those are goals that are like maybe a
little bit beyond your control
and it might not work out that way so i
think
what you should your goals should be
more
um based in instead of like what is
something that you can do that can get
you to snl
or what is something that you can do
that can get you to late night
is focus on that goal rather than that
end goal so
be like i'm going to write five new
characters
and i'm going to put them online that is
my goal for this year or
i'm going to write a joke every day or
every hour
about what's going on in the news
because i feel like
that'll make you feel better you've hit
your goal that is something that you can
control
and then i guarantee you the other stuff
will happen
and you will get work that way rather
than being like
focusing on the prize you should focus
on the work if you're serious about
becoming a comedian
join our facebook group linked in the
description below to start getting tips
like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing today
[Music]